monte un tout petit peu encore souffles
un tout petit peu je vois
le c'est
bon le soleil sort ouais ça sort ça
sort on aussi un petit plan trip alors
ouais c'est
bien
voà le soleil
repart
dans vas-y
coup ça
tourne oh là là
ok c'est bon à partir de
là
ou
compromis je pense que ça
passe
boncher allez coupe
B
la bonne femme en couleur qui est assis
entre les deux voilà celle la bonne
femme
de
M
de mettre à chaque fois alors des fois
pas tu peux
raeler ça commence à vibre là
oh à
toi
dans le centre ville moi je me rappelle
marché beaucoup plus grand ça
czire à l'URE le
me à souffler
des
regarde fait
chier ouais c'est pas
grave m mouvement monter
làdedans
ve
queou attends les détails et après on
l d'accord
c'est vachement beau çae du monde ça que
j'aeas bien fait un plan cette valeur là
dans de
nous avec
les
ok cou dans
le laiss bien vivre ça c'est beau
ça pass plein de choses là tu
vois le camion c'est
pas ouais ouais
ouais allez
C oh ah désolé ouais on reprend à partir
de là alors on recommence c'est mieux
encore les deux qui ti la
main frère comment tu vas ser
OK
c t
t ah j'adore quand ça bouge comme ça
j'adore quand
c'est des mecs de partout
superanticiper
ça
pense qu'il y a du monde parce que il y
a c'est le train là tu vois tuas le
train tu as
le
ou ça passe ça passe ça
passe ça
reste à gauche
ou
c'est bien ça discute sur les ballots
c'est vachement
beau
des mes
partout
allezou non
Contin
j'adore
pas ces plans là on s'enira pas
beaucoup rentre dedans rentre dedans
rentre dedans
j'adore allez rentre
R
ah ça c'est vachement beau ça j'adore
ça j'en fait c'est vachement B ça
j'adore vas-y tu peux continuer
de face en bas de face Fran oui de face
je sais pas je sais pas je laisse faire
je laisse faire je laisse connerie non
non on est pas de connerie ça va comme
ça on n pas un poil mou
là regarde comme c'est beau ça regarde
ça regarde làdedans regarde là-dedans
comme c'est beau ça regarde làdedans
c'est top ça reste là Fran s'il te
plaît voilà ça c'est vachement beau ça
regardee de côté complètement
tu vois voilà qui sé
complètement regarde un peu moins là
voilà c'est vachement beau comme plan
j'adore ça dira une photo de salale
cadeau là vas-y continue
tranquille continue à
tourner soleil arrive ouais j'ai merci
c'est moins beau au soleil hein j'adore
ça j'adore cet endroit c'est même plus
beau quand j'ai pas de soleil
va faire la
fripe
comme c'est beau ça c'est un beau plan
ça c'est sublime ça tu as vu le tas de
trucs qui tiennent les trois mecs en bas
là tu sors de là ou
tu encore je crois j' pas tu CIS non non
mais tout à l'heure j'ai un
petit
il y a y a du matos
derrière c'est B va doucement va
doucement va doucement le temps de le
voir s continue à traving le soleil
arrive
merci
ok bon pour toi allez
fix allez
4 on un peu en bas de l'image aussi he
voilà g
ici les gens qui passent autour ça c'est
bien
ça néo
là c'est sûr qu'un plan comme ça avec la
22 tu peux pas le
faire
ça bouge vachement c'est vachement bien
çaas les vélos les gens qui
passent zoom sur les vêtements pe plus
j'arrive attends je termine ça voilà je
un vélo allez
c bien qu'on voie les
vêtements cher regarde c'est vachement
bien qui cherche un truc à sa
taille pas c bê mon c'est des trucs
arriv d'Europe États-Unis tu arrivve de
partout
ça et ça ça tue le marché local ce que
Don la Croix Rouge he c'est revendu hein
c'est pareil hein ah ouais c'est pas
donné bah non la Croix Rouge ils font du
FR tu veux il pe ça pass bien quoi en
tu sais c'est
des pas plus vertical peut-être s'il te
plaît Fran comme ça on verra peut-être
plus les Frip un peu doucement tout lui
il va pas y arriver attends attends
attends j'arrive il faut que je me cal l
peut-être ouais un autre un autre valeur
comme ça là
ou sur le sur vraiment sur le temp les
mecs qui qui travaillent dessus serré
sur les mecs qui qui cherchent là voilà
tu vois attends attends c'est bien ça et
là je suis vraiment à la
pique pas
facile ça ça ça rigole pas rigole pas
les mecs ça cherche ça plaisante pas du
tout hein donne presque envie d'y aller
là je suis sûr qu'il y a du nor face et
du Colombia
là-dedans est-ce que tu peux décadrer un
peu pour en voir plus autour tu vois
j'arrive attends C
tuas le F laisse tomber voilà des gens
qui passe voilà tu as un mec qui passe
c'est la fripe c'est la vie voilà ça ge
des fr qui
arriv voil bon peux en sortir quand tu
veux avis a
ass un stock de les
là t les vêts que tu donnes tu
sais
nettoyé
j'aurais bien un mec sur le un mec sur
le Charon de PO ça aura
top encore des là encore un peu
fr encore un peu de Frip avec de gens de
parapl tuas tout à l'heure ça c'est j ça
très
beau va changir ça comme
[Musique]
ças ou en Afrique ça
rigole
j'ai bien fait pas mettre que 100
l l'école avec tous les enfants qui VO
je une photo avec eux alors ouais tuas
pas entendu ah ouais mais j'ai pas
compris qu'il y avait plein
d'enfant presque plus beau sans soleil à
mon
avis il y a tellement de bordel que
lesomble
de
ils sont tous alignés devant le bâtiment
les gamins ok allez cut alors on va
làbord faire la